maintenant vous allez faire un bon dodo
mais si jamais j'avais un mauvais rêve
je suis sûr qu'on peut surmonter
n'importe quel rêve et si jamais je rêve
où tu nous envoies dans un endroit tout
noir un endroit horrible et si sa
demande est tellement triste et j'avais
tellement peur d'être noir que je me
mette à apprendre que poison
eco gym empoisonné comme ça pour le
reste de ma vie
et puis mon coeur ce cas sont un morceau
et je peux plus rien sur un tir d'obus
et qu'à la fin je supporte plus alors il
faut que je mange
je me retrouve sur une table enfants
avec ma bouche qui veut plus ouvrir
est-ce que tu viendrais nous réveiller
si on a un rêve comme ça
pourtant on n'est pas comme toutes les
autres familles ont dit différent
ce qu'on a grandi là bas
la hausse
quant à mr n'était pas folle
plus que ta soeur ton frère aux
toilettes
c'est cette maison
[Applaudissements]
c'est horrible rêve que tu craignais de
faire il ne pourra plus de faire de
belles bien sûr que je dirais l'airé